who do you have like uh on the Mount
Rushmore of Street skating
man Mount Rushmore Street skating I
might even go over because I got I was
solid I'd say probably like four okay
mine is
Paul's up there for so
p-rod Eric costan guy Mariano okay
Heath Curts are Mark Johnson like those
that those like those are like my list
and those like when I think about it
just like not only like tricks right but
Style just like you know how I had Eric
Austin Shoes yeah at some point in time
yeah he had a fire shoot
at knees uh no he was on uh no Eric
Carson was on uh s
yeah it was yes it was s that's what it
was I knew there was an e
[Laughter]
um yeah Eric Austin I'm trying to think
what about on the vert side obviously
Tony uh the first shot yeah Tony
obviously like you know OG Legend
Pioneer I would say Bob Burnquist
Burnquist was that guy he's Brazilian
right yeah I think I used to be him on
Tony Hawk he's like King and Ember so I
went there for a contest and like
they're like yeah they're gonna have
like a little function at like Bob's
Island because the guy who I always
wanted to party with as a kid Chad Muska
what what would he think Chad musk uh
Street skating street legend he pulls up
like some of the uh skate contests and
like kicks on the side and watches it
he's still laid back oh just Vibes I
remember him having some fly [ __ ] too
some gear super yeah the musket highs
yeah yeah yep yep yep damn the super era
of Life yeah Super Crew error out it was
like Supra crew
um and I was I wrote I rode for them for
a little bit when I was younger yeah so
it was like that was like Anton and all
those dudes are still on like I remember
going and seeing like TK at the
warehouse and being like Oh my God like
right TK like Antoine like and those
like those dudes had like the best
selling shoes on super too